God by Nature has designed this such
that you cannot prove he did it because
if you prove he did it that's like
finding you you donated you're like I
did it anonymously but you find the
receipt somewhere so by its nature you
have to come to the conclusion because
it's such a gift it's the greatest gift
I gave this to you anonymously you don't
you can curse my name and I will still
give you life that's amazing I will
still give Sam Harris the best life even
I was just thinking that when he said
even if he curses me and gets many
people riled up and cause of suffering
I'm sorry you're still given existence
and I will not have I will not come down
from the clouds and say and announce
myself and even that you can doubt so no
matter what I will give you the gift of
a doubting of doubting too God is lacks
ego yes lacks so much ego that he made
it contrive this in such a way that you
cannot prove him because to prove him
would be that this gift was not given
anony and that's the greatest gift of
all that's beautiful